What do you know about the multiverse
we should tell him the truth
careful steven this path exacts a heavy toll
Welcome back everyone this will be my brand new
doctor strange multiverse of madness super bowl
trailer video for the alternate trailer with
completely different footage in a bunch of other
easter eggs i know there's so many questions about
some of these big wtf moments especially what's
going on with professor x the illuminati team i
think i've figured out everybody that's on the
team and what's going on with some of these other
avengers variants like this captain marvel variant
so if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos i'm sure we're
going to be talking about this for the next couple
of months until the movie comes out just because
every time they release new footage it raises
more questions than it answers in a good way
real quick shout out to my friends at
keeps who asked to sponsor this video
keeps is a subscription service that helps
people like professor x of the x-men keep their
hair because hooking your head into cerebral for
many many years is the quickest way to hair loss
that in fighting apocalypse seriously he had a
ton of hair before he started doing that two out
of three people and superheroes will experience
hair loss by the time they're 35 and i'm not
talking about getting it burned off in a fire or
chopped off at the neck with a giant blade while
you're fighting crime but keeps has you covered
they offer clinically proven research-backed
treatments to stop hair loss and improve hair
growth with keeps you can get quality expert
care without ever visiting a doctor's office or
pharmacy all their treatment plans are doctor
recommended and delivered straight to your door
at about half the cost of a traditional pharmacy
hair loss stops with keeps so to get 50 off your
first order go to keeps.com emergencyawesome or
click the link in the description that's k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash emergency awesome but i'll just
start with the full illuminati team because i know
that's the biggest question on everyone's mind
here like which variants here from which universes
which fox marvel characters did they bring back
from the fantastic four from the x-men movies we
have confirmed patrick stewart professor x he sits
here right over doctor strange's shoulder where
the third chair would be the reason you don't
see a third chair sticking up over his shoulder
is because he's in that special floating chair
based on the concept art it looks exactly like
the chair that professor x used during x-men the
animated series like it just kind of floats around
it seems like there's no chair in the middle here
there were six members of the original illuminati
marvel comic book team so it sounds like there
are six members of this team and there's just a
space in the middle three chairs and then three
chairs on the other side but just because there
are only six members of this illuminati team that
doesn't mean they'll be the only variants of
big avengers characters that we'll see because
it does seem like they have a bunch of other
variants from other universes working for them
the character on the left of dr strange sitting
in the chair there in the shadows seems like a
black panther variant you can see what looks like
a large giant necklace piece around his upper neck
when you really crank up the picture it seems like
it's silver and thicker like killmonger's neck
piece that he wore so this seems like a killmonger
black panther variant from another universe black
panther was one of the original illuminati members
in the comics it makes sense that a version of him
from the multiverse would be on the team we saw
a multiverse killmonger black panther during the
marvel what if episodes even though he kind of
went off the rails and stole ultron's infinity
gauntlet armor but just to be clear this would not
be the same killmonger black panther from what if
it would be a totally different version on doctor
strange's right it seems like this is a female
character with long hair so it could wind up being
a version of captain carter because we know from
her shield that appears in the official poster
that she's going to be in the movie the version of
captain carter from the marvel what if series they
did confirm that some of the what-if characters
would show up in live-action captain carter being
the first one but then the other person here who's
walking in past the chairs that so many of you
have asked me blade questions about is actually
just the same version of baron mordo with the long
hair who comes to arrest doctor strange and take
him back to the illuminati's base the voice over
dialogue says your crimes against reality can't go
unpunished so basically he is a version of mordo
working with the illuminati and it seems like
based on his outfit that he is a version of mordo
from the multiverse in his universe he became a
version of the sorcerer's supreme but i think
the idea here putting him on this team is that
he's meant to fill the role that dr strange did on
the original comic book roster like he fills the
role of magic user on the team there's still two
empty chairs to fill i do agree that the ultron
robots that come escorting him in belong to the
iron man variant that would also be on this team
played by some other actor who's not robert downey
jr it would be cool if he's a version of superior
iron man because he was kind of like an extra big
a-hole and it kind of seems like they're going
for that vibe with this illuminati team as for
that last member of the team the rumor is that
the other member will either be a version of black
bolt from the inhumans or a reed richards variant
of the fantastic four there were a lot of rumors
that john krasinski could have a cameo scene as a
version of mr fantastic from the multiverse but if
they're bringing back patrick stewart's professor
x from the fox marvel movies they could also
bring back the fox marvel version of reed richards
talking about this character now i know there are
so many questions and theories about this person
i've seen so many people try to adjust the
photoshop settings to try and get a better look
at this people wondering if it's superior iron
man if it's nova if it's a kang variant because
they look african american but it's actually meant
to be a captain marvel variant played by what it
seems like maria rambeau monica rambeau's mother
so you kind of get the logic here you see where
i'm going with this she's got the exact same power
signature as captain marvel the same armor type
it looks a little bit different it's not
the exact same armor but it's similar armor
so we know she's a captain marvel variant and
she's got a super short buzz cut hairdo that
looks exactly like lashanna lynch's hair in bond
no time to die but her backstory would be that she
came from a universe where she was the test pilot
on the day that captain marvel got her powers
when the tesseract engine blew up irradiating her
with infinity stone energy from the space stone
like in her universe that was the difference it
was maria rambeau during the 90s in the jet that
day not carol danvers so maria rambeau became
captain marvel in her universe and that would
be why in present day she looks the exact same
age she has an age since the 90s because of the
way captain marvel's powers work also in this
illuminati base in this separate room there are
these special holding cells with what seems like a
christine palmer variant with red hair in a white
costume managing all these other people in white
lab coats who are running around all crazy like
something is going nuts this dark tech ultron
robot is just running through like it's chasing
someone down we also see that they got america
chavez and one of their holding cells and the
other holding cell is empty i think everything is
going crazy here because in the other footage we
see they zoom in on this scarlet witch variants
eyeball and you can see the reflection of the
rest of the room with these two holding cells
she's covered in blood you see america chavez
in her reflection in the eyeball later you see her
fighting that maria rambeau captain marvel variant
so i think the reason everything is going crazy is
because this scarlet witch variant busts in starts
killing a bunch of people to try and take america
chavez because she would need her powers to travel
the multiverse and get back to her version of
west view and it seems like in pursuit of that
trying to take america chavez back break her out
of this cell she winds up just killing a bunch of
illuminati members like that's why she's covered
in blood because she's been killing a whole bunch
of people in this base so r.i.p mcu illuminati
there's also concept art confirming some of this
there's concept art of this version of professor
x trying to use his telepathic powers to fight
this scarlet witch variant in plain clothes maybe
that's why patrick stewart agreed to come back as
professor x because it was going to be a really
big deal but it was kind of a one-off and this
scarlet witch winds up killing him and a lot of
these other illuminati variants i don't know if
they would kill off the entire team because i do
love the idea of this multiverse team it's sort
of like a council of ricks inside the mcu even
though the council of ricks and rick and morty is
inspired by marvel's council of reeds which is a
bunch of versions of reed richards and at the end
of rick and morty season 5 evil morty basically
destroys the council of ricks in their ability
to control the multiverse the central finite curve
so it sounds like this scarlet witch variant maybe
both versions of scarlet witch are going to pull
an evil morty and just destroy whatever's going
on here at this illuminati base first it's rick
and morty borrowing from marvel then it's marvel
barring from rick and morty if you didn't realize
the person who wrote doctor strange multiverse
of madness this movie was also a writer on
rick and morty for several seasons so it's
not a coincidence that you're getting a lot of
counsel of rick's rick and morty vibes with this
then to explain what's going on with the marvel
zombies of it all because there's not one but two
versions of zombie characters in this there's
zombie doctor strange in a zombie scarlet witch
zombie doctor strange we can actually see turning
into a zombie like he's looking at himself as it's
happening freaking out like oh my god then in the
other trailer footage after he's fully been turned
he starts using crazy dark magic spells going
nuts a lot of you also spotted this connection too
this spell where you see all these dark arms
come out of him is meant to be a dark copy of
the same scene from avengers infinity war where he
manifests all these arms out of himself and splits
himself into a bunch of different copies to fight
thanos if you zoom in enhance on the red accents
in his costume in the highlights in his hair
he looks like defender strange who's just been
turned into a zombie somehow the zombie scarlet
witch just seems like it's the same variant
in plain clothes covered in blood fighting the
illuminati in the other footage she rips through
this wall with her chaos magic here and the design
seems the exact same as this structure here where
we see our main mcu doctor strange with christine
palmer variant in america chavez staring at this
space with a special artifact so maybe this
version of scarlet witch is after whatever's in
this space here and the illuminati is protecting
it for some reason you can post all your theories
about what you think this is it seems like some
sort of nexus for all of reality something that
the illuminati would be protecting we don't know
why they become zombies maybe they get corrupted
by some crazy darkhold spell gone nuts or maybe
they just get bitten by some other marvel zombie
that the illuminati had been holding captive in
their facility that just escapes during the chaos
they also confirmed my theory about our main mcu
scarlet witch being the one to attack kamar taj
and all these other scenes at camartage the whole
idea is that she's come for america chavez who
dr strange and wong are trying to protect because
america chavez is supposed to be the only one who
can physically travel to other universes there's
also a new scene of america chavez being attacked
by gargantos here and for those of you asking
his tentacles are also the ones that you see in
the background of the special marvel studios
logo here it's just meant to be a gargantos
easter egg a lot of you also asked questions about
scarlet witch and nexus beings if scarlet witch is
supposed to be a nexus being how can she have a
variant normally in the comics nexus beings are
the same in every single reality so scarlet witch
will be the exact same version everywhere you go
in every universe i think they change the way they
visualize that just a little bit for the purposes
of the movie like they have this version looking
a little bit different so that filthy casuals who
don't read a ton of comic books can understand
who is fighting who like which version is which
version when things get crazy on screen but she is
a nexus being so i think the idea is that both of
their power levels are the same like you see her
using the same type of chaos magic and she seems
like she's powerful enough to kill some of these
crazy op illuminati members but if you spotted any
other big easter eggs in the trailer footage that
i didn't talk about in the video just write them
below in the comments we'll get more trailers as
we get closer to the movie coming out i'll do more
bonus videos too everyone click here for my other
big doctor strange multiverse of madness trailer
video with totally different footage and click
here for my marvel moon knight super bowl trailer
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!